[Music]
please try to relax after all you were
chosen to be here I shall now test
rakaat our compatibility and her
potential to join the anti our community
was regarding
I say test but please don't concern
yourself with such words all will be
well
I assure you the Restless guard already
knows all about our nation's potential I
wish you the best
[Applause]
incompatible not this one
look closely
they show the same spirit you did after
your baptism Julius congratulations you
have risen where others would fall you
have become a God Eater soon the power
that sings through your veins will be
awakened you will be welcomed into our
elite Special Forces the blood unions
blood are my chosen soldiers superior to
all other god eaters my finest Warriors
will herald a new dawn for all humankind
for now rest you must recover your full
strength I expect
[Music]
ah I hear congratulations are in order
on the results of your compatibility
test I'm glad of your success please sit
this is the most peaceful location on
frier and come here when I have free
time to reflect my apologies
I haven't properly introduced myself my
name is Julius Visconti I serve as
captain of the blood special forces unit
which you will soon be joining please no
need to be nervous I'm rather looking
forward to working with you well I have
some tasks to attend to
feel free to tour frier once you've
gotten some rest you'll speak again soon
I'm certain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of the most crucial tasks in any
conflict is to understand your
surroundings take a look around good
looking now then focus straight ahead
all right
your keen eyes work well enough next to
movement there's two raised platforms
there go ahead and climb them if you
will sometimes that difference in
elevation can be the difference between
victory and defeat event always be
conscious of your stamina pushing too
hard and losing your breath and battle
can end in death let's get a quick
warm-up in why don't you run around for
a bit
excellent feeling good now on to the key
of your life is a God Eater combat that
weapon you wield is a god Ark the only
tool capable of harming in origami yes
there you will see some monster tomorrow
egami
or you can test your blade upon personal
you might imagine you can switch to a
ranged weapon gun for transform your Ark
and fire at the city life Oracle power
always watch closely to make sure you
don't tire yourself out these are the
absolute basics to go ahead and make use
of them again origami before you lets
your master this training you will join
blood on the field in real battle
[Music]
[Music]
hey there
you were so freakin super amazing out
there today you're a newbie huh I mean
new to this blood special course you
know what I mean
I'm manic uzuki Connect second class
I just got brought up to you it's so
awesome to meet you
I sure do
who does it maliciousness is universal
I thought eaters gotta keep her strength
them eating is just another form of
training right oh by the way as a token
of our newfound friendship Sam it it's
my mom's secret super special recipe an
amazing Oden sandwich give it a try bet
you love it whoops training starts any
minute now
I almost totally zoned sandwiches are a
blessing and a curse
Carrie gotta run see you soon
oh hey I'll be really mad if you leave
even a single crab so enjoy
[Music]
you
let's have a brief review Joey first
slay this enemy last opponent and avoid
an origami strike open your shield do
you no good if you've been knocked out
still healing does take time the best
way I've found to open up that space is
with stun grenades no I want you to face
that origami once more
when an opening appears to power your
enemy then burst and slay the others
arrayed against
this is power
precious materials from its core such
will enable further research adventure
you can also collect any scraps of
materials that fall during battle for
the sake of practice some material has
been left in the training rooms hunted
down training will end in 20 seconds and
with that we conclude your basic
training
you are now ready to join our blood
Special Forces
[Music]
[Music]
hey I've never seen you two around
before
oh you're the new recruits everyone's
been talking about yes sir we're both
really excited to work with you sir
sir that has a nice ring to it
names Romeo there's anything you need to
know I'm your guy ask away
I'll tell you one thing though blood is
tough so you'd better be ready to give
it your all huh oh well that's a good
question so thus um
what is okay so there's this blood power
and if if it you know wakes up you did
these cool skills our captain skill is
super awesome he comes up against an
origami right and then red slash bozo he
just crushes the thing that's so cool
can you tell us about your special skill
sir romeo sir oh hey come on don't ask
that kind of thing i it's not easy to
get a special skill got a personal oh I
know why did you take those questions to
dr. Rachel she's the one who found in
blood see ya huh is question-and-answer
time over already can I ask something I
shouldn't have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa awesome
you
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
captain Julian I was not informed that
you would be a company than you my
apologies friend I simply have a great
deal of confidence in them I wish to see
their talents firsthand
[Music]
yes of course good you're here in that
second class now to Kazuki reporting for
duty in the blood Special Forces units
sir I'm so super proud to be here
welcome to blood I am captain Julius
Visconti now that further ado let's
begin your field training what look out
there those are the beasts that threaten
the future of the human race the origami
how you slay them is of no concern but
do not halt until they stop breathing
understood
wait you mean what we're fighting
origami like right now like for real
indeed cadet you would learn little if
you never fought in a real battlefield
simply do all that I know you can and
those monsters will pose no threat all
right
[Applause]
[Music]
humanity has faced enemies since ancient
times humanity has always prevailed I
know we do not have sharp fangs and
rending claws to face off against our
foes but we have gifts they do not
possess strategy unity cooperation and
most of all the strength of will that
binds us together willpower is the
fiercest weapon our fiercest weapon
never forget that it's time for word
[Music]
this missions are unusually prone to
violence
[Music]
are not even trying
[Music]
oh very well
ARC's up prepare to defend yourselves
[Music]
cadets you've done well today this is an
ideal opportunity to demonstrate the
abilities you are to awaken wow so
awesome I focused that willpower to
execute a blood art stand fast what's
the blood art a talent that can shift
the very tide of battle in your favor
blood arts our innate skills forged of
the fire in your veins
yeah
that was a blood art this power within
us will constantly develop and
strengthen as we do with it we can face
any origami always remember that this is
a part of you nothing can stand against
it
you
[Music]